what makes someone a hero there is never
just
one answer to that question some will
tell you that it's selflessness
putting other people before oneself that
makes someone
heroic others believe that heroism takes
someone with a clear sense of morality
the ability to tell right from wrong
with absolute
certainty perhaps a hero should also be
a symbol
a paragon of hope and virtue for all of
society to look up to
and aspire to be and then there are
those who would argue that a person
can't possibly be a hero
unless they possess one key trait
whether that comes as a result of a
freak accident
gamma radiation exposure or mutated
genes
being blessed with extraordinary powers
and the will to use them for good
might just be what elevates a moral
selfless and
symbolic hero into something more a
super
hero it is rare that the scp foundation
encounters an anomalous creature or
entity that it considers to be harmless
there are of course exceptions but
perhaps even more of a rarity is an scp
that seeks to go out of its way and use
its anomalous abilities to do good
so many of the creatures and entities
kept contained by the foundation
have malicious intent like damage
regenerating reptiles with contempt for
humanity
and eldritch beings with desires to take
over this dimension
but then there is scp-2800 or as he
prefers to call himself
cactus man the spiked menace partially
human
and part succulent plant scp-2800 is one
of a rare breed of scps
one that aims to help people rather than
killing them
enslaving them or wiping reality as we
know it from existence
and as you might be surprised to learn
that this superhero known as cactus man
began life as one
daniel mcintyre an average guy from
scotland
little is known about daniel's origin
story all superheroes have one of course
but as far as foundation researchers are
aware
cactus man wasn't jettisoned in a pod
from his dying homeworld to the safety
of earth
it is also safe to assume he didn't get
pricked by a radioactive cactus
or have his dna infused with a plant
during a genetic experiment
he was first encountered by the scp
foundation whilst they were trying to
contain
another scp a reality warping object
that had somehow breached containment
what foundation staff tracking the
object witnessed was cactus man
attempting to assault the escaped scp
too little success following this
encounter
foundation personnel convinced cactus
man to allow them to contain him
he complied was designated as scp-2800
and researchers began investigating the
nature of this strange would-be
superhero according to daniel one day
his powers just
happened with little understanding as to
how why
or what had caused this transformation
when asked about how he acquired his
powers during an interview with scp
foundation researcher dr love
daniel said taviana stock i don't know
i woke up one day and boom cactus powers
thought i might as well use them for
good right
i always grew up reading a lot of comic
books always loved the x-men as a little
kid
so i thought i was one of them i thought
i was the luckiest guy in the world
ending up with super powers doesn't
every kid wish they could be a superhero
analysis by foundation research staff
revealed that daniel's dna had somehow
merged with the genome of a carnegie
gigantea plant or a saguaro cactus
this plant is usually what most people
picture if they were to imagine a
typical cactus
and is known to be native to the sonoran
desert as well as the mexican state of
sonora
how one became part of daniel mcintyre's
genetic makeup is baffling
it seems highly unlikely that a saguaro
cactus would grow naturally in scotland
given that the country has a far damper
and colder climate than the scorching
hot deserts that saguaros normally
thrive in
regardless of exactly how daniel became
fused with a cactus
his body shares a number of the same
physical properties of the plant
pointed spikes protrude from his skin
which can grow to just over an inch in
length
it seems that scp-2800 can either remove
these spikes manually with little pain
or will eventually shed them naturally
over time allowing more to regrow in
their place
as well as outwardly looking like an
anthropomorphic cactus
scp-2800 also shares various biological
traits with his cacti counterparts
daniel's body no longer functions in the
same way as that of an ordinary human
being in a number of different ways
firstly he is able to perform
photosynthesis deriving the necessary
nutrients he requires from direct
sunlight
this negates the need for him to consume
any food
and prevents him from feeling hunger or
the fatigue this can often bring
additionally his altered biology allows
cactus men to store more water than
would normally be possible for the
average human
and he requires less of it too scp-2800
is able to keep himself hydrated with a
third of the required fluids for an
average person daniel can also adapt to
more arid environments
with drier climates and above average
levels of heat having little
impact on his abilities speaking of
abilities
scp-2800 is not just a man with the
physical and biological traits of a
saguaro cactus
he also has superpowers that seem well
let's say
inspired by a cactus while perhaps not
as flashy as being faster than a
speeding bullet
more powerful than a locomotive or able
to leap tall buildings in a single bound
cactus man does possess his own unique
set of superhuman
abilities derived like his other traits
from his parts saguaro dna
scp-2800 has the power to empathetically
communicate with other plant life
unlike telepathy and the ability to
communicate solely through thoughts
empaths like cactus men are able to
influence or interpret the emotions or
moods of others so similar but a little
more subtle
in its effectiveness cactus man might
have superhuman powers alter dna and a
mysterious origin
but another part of a hero's journey is
the struggle and scp-2800
is no exception to this either despite
his desire to do good
he harbors a lot of unrest under that
prickly exterior
after extensive psychological
examination by the researchers at the
scp foundation
daniel was diagnosed with two distinct
mental disorders
the first of these is dysmithia or
chronic depression
with the other being a condition
colloquially known as hero syndrome
hero syndrome as its name suggests is
often characterized by an
unstoppable pathological urge to help
people
usually ignoring any risks to oneself in
the pursuit of assisting even total
strangers
some with this disorder will even
attempt to manufacture dangerous
scenarios in order to act like the hero
and earn themselves recognition and
praise for reacting heroically to the
danger they
secretly caused like for example
committing arson so they can save people
from a burning building
scp-2800 has never attempted anything
like this so far
but cactus man does express an extreme
willingness to help people
and try to intervene in any situation
that he thinks he can assist with
the problem is scp-2800 is hardly an
experienced crime fighter
and this has put him on the receiving
end of his fair share of
injuries during his first outing as
cactus man the spiked menace
daniel encountered a group engaging in
the sale of illicit substances
and attempted to apprehend them while he
was able to deal a cactus spine-filled
blow to one of their faces
the group quickly overpowered cactus men
and beat him until local law enforcement
arrived to save him
determined to prove himself a hero
though daniel returned to patrolling the
streets soon after
but met with the same results even weak
petty criminals seemed like they were
too much for cactus man to handle
while his hero syndrome compels scp-2800
to want to do good and
set a good example it is also directly
linked to his other condition
his dysmithia by attempting and failing
to be heroic
cactus man becomes chronically depressed
yet still has the urges brought on by
his hero syndrome to put himself in
harm's way for the sake of others
and when he is unable to provide help
daniel falls back into depression
it's a very difficult cycle in the hopes
of counteracting some of daniel's
struggles
the scp foundation have gifted him a
pair of potted cacti
these occupy scp-2800 cell with him
both oxygenating his room as well as
boosting his morale
although he has remarked that the cacti
don't say much to him beyond i'm thirsty
and
i am a cactus daniel has affectionately
named his potted plants they're now
known as cactilad
and spiky girl his sidekicks in the
never ending battle against evil
during interviews with foundation
researcher dr love
daniel admitted that he was a victim of
bullying throughout much of his
childhood
from a young age he often found himself
in physical altercations with bullies
that singled him out and picked on him
at school
cactus man said that his experiences
encouraged him to give back
and that despite having suffered at the
hands of bullies it made scp-2800
determined to help others
in need in his own words daniel didn't
want what happened to him
to happen to anybody else and it is
highly likely that these experiences
from his youth are at least part of the
cause of his hero syndrome
however another incident may also be
linked to scp-2800's condition
despite not often prevailing against
petty criminals there is cctv
surveillance footage of cactus man from
before his containment by the scp
foundation
the footage in question was taken at a
subway close to where daniel patrolled
and looked for criminals to apprehend
in the surveillance tape a woman and her
child can be seen waiting at the subway
station near a support pillar
from behind the pillar an assailant in a
mask appeared wielding what looked to be
a knife
the woman cowering and trying to protect
her child was made to open her purse
as the attacker threatened her with his
knife but then
cactus man appeared behind the man he
walked up to him
and punched him in his lower back and
chest a number of scp-2800
sharp cacti spines ended up lodged in
the man's skin
causing him to drop the knife in pain
during the ensuing scuffle
scp-2800 was able to tie the man up
thus saving the woman and her child the
woman then thanked cactus man
shaking his hand and embracing him her
child also expressed gratitude
with scp-2800 kneeling down to face them
and appearing to get emotional
at receiving recognition after signing
an autograph for the child
cactus man then disappeared from the
scene before police arrived
cacti have the tenacity to grow in
barren desert environments
surviving on very little water it is for
that reason
that to some these plants have come to
symbolize strength
resilience and endurance this one
encounter captured in this surveillance
footage may well have been one of the
few times cactus man
ever succeeded at being heroic but
perhaps it is all he needed to encourage
him to keep trying
to seek out wrongdoings time and time
again
even if it led to him being injured
maybe knowing that just once he had
succeeded in saving a woman
and her child was enough to convince him
that he would one day be able to do so
again and maybe that is what makes
someone
a true hero the power to endure
now check out scp-682 waze scp
foundation tried to kill hard to destroy
reptile
and scp-096 the shy guy for more
anomalies that have the power to endure
in spades